hello everyone I have a YouTube channel
on YouTube called the volgen and I
create an SCP
related audio recordings to narrations
I think I well I thought today I would
do something different because this SCP
containment breach Kim has been featured
on the front page of their CP wiki for
quite a while now and I thought that I
would play it I'll also show everybody
what my real voice is as I'll never have
another excuse to do so so without any
further ado let's let's jump right in
as they say the name I suppose I'll just
stick to my YouTube channel name
difficulty well I think I'll go Kidder
or cat or level difficulty because I'm
essentially a fearless bastard so okay
let's let's start oh I wonder what this
is gonna be like looks pretty fun though
the Let's Plays I watched have been
quite good Oh check it out
the first differenct oh god [ __ ] of
these crash test dummies what the oh you
blink in this yeah
holy [ __ ] he should chief you look good
how do you manually blink CPU wants to
press B and pressing all the buttons all
of the pochiro [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
run away run No oh Jesus oh my god no oh
my god I don't like this game I don't
like it I do not like it what is going
on
oh [ __ ] oh Jesus what is happening I'm
scared oh [ __ ] oh I don't like this I do
not like this game holy I'm gonna I
ain't gonna pay Oh Oh mr. lights is
there not even a torch or a gum I know
I'm d-class but Jesus Christ it's a
lockdown oh let's close this
but it just disappear and reappear I
don't know a time switch closes the door
automatically okay Jesus bone [ __ ]
that's okay I am too scared to play this
game I don't want to go in there about
things in there I don't want to die it's
not a learning work it is nice it is
nice oh that's [ __ ] terrifying
what the hell what the [ __ ] what am I
supposed to do I'm not going in there
[ __ ] not
[ __ ] not in the book and now it's gone
again oh [ __ ] I still haven't figured
out how to manually blink either what is
this books and stuff I've been in here
before I'm just going around in circles
because I'm not going back to the
[ __ ] Red Room it's red gas mask I
eyes for inventory no Jesus what the
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
is going on oh my god [ __ ] this [ __ ]
[ __ ] les no just no [ __ ] this [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] me